[Musique]
bienvenue dans le canton de guebwiller
une zone de 37 mille habitants qui
compte désormais 18 communes après
l'annexion du canton de soultz en 2015
avec sept grands crus les dominicains et
le pays d'art et d'histoire
ce territoire ne manque pas d'atouts
mais pour la ville de guebwiller commune
nature crédité d'une deuxième libellules
fin 2016 ainsi que pour le reste du
canton
la question environnementale est au
centre de toutes les préoccupations au
coeur de la vallée du florival
l'eau est l'une des plus pures du
territoire est l'un des vecteurs
importants de l'économie début de notre
escapade en grande pompe ce l'un des
lieux symboliques du canton entouré du
markstein et du grand ballon nous sommes
ici donc sur le barrage de la loche qui
est une retenue qui a été construite par
les allemands à l'époque et qui est une
retenue importante parce qu'elle a trois
rôles premier rôle qui est donc la
réserve d'eau potable de la vallée du
florival deuxième rôle pour le soutien
d'étiage au fleuve rouge de la rivière
de la loge et troisièmes rôles qui peut
servir en cas de crue puisque c'est une
retenue qui peut être nous permettre de
sécuriser les crues dans la vallée des
travaux importants sont prévus en accord
avec bien sûr l'état puisque c'est
l'état qui est toujours propriétaire de
ce barrage c'est le seul du département
d'ailleurs qui est dans ce cas et il est
question de le transférer au département
après des travaux de sécurisation qui
sont dus un problème sismique
ce barrage contient aujourd'hui est
limité à 400 mille mètres cubes de
réserves et avec des travaux importants
pourrait passer à 7 170 mille mètres
cubes ce qui permettrait une réserve
beaucoup plus importante évidemment de
l'eau potable au niveau du bassin
versant et donc dans ce sillage il y
aura aussi la continuité écologique de
la loge puisque ça permet de garder la
le vivier de de poissons et de et de
tous les éléments écologiques qui
peuvent survivre dans ce dans cette
rivière qui va je lui rappelle se jeter
dans l'île au niveau de colmar
après avoir délaissé les auteurs nous
faisons une halte à la station de
traitement des eaux potables à soultz
situé à la sortie de jungholtz
l'activité y bat son plein et de
nombreux traitements sont effectués
quotidiennement pour maintenir une bonne
qualité d'eau nous avons deux stations
de traitement de l'eau potable sur le
canton une si tu avais l'air et nous
avons choisi de vous présenter celle de
soultz nous sommes aujourd'hui à 110
mètres cubes aux heures ce qui est un
super une super production normalement
en temps en temps optimale ça peut aller
monter jusqu'à 200 mètres cubes
c'est une eau très particulière très
riche et nous avons visité tout à
l'heure et vu que les truites veille au
grain puisqu'elles sont dans un bocal et
si évidemment à chaque heure tout est
contrôlé si elle même ne se nourrissent
pas bien ne vont pas bien c'est que la
qualité de l'eau est en chute libre donc
des traitements sont tout de suite
organisé derrière des traitements
évidemment pas nocif pour la santé mais
il est essentiel de rappeler à nos
jeunes générations que l'eau est la
richesse de demain la richesse que l'on
va devoir préserver et éviter de
gaspiller le territoire souhaite
préserver l'environnement et a décidé de
produire de l'énergie hydraulique à la
faveur d'une vis d'archimède ce système
également appelé la vis sans fin
sert à pomper l'eau afin de la remontée
à la surface
exemple du côté de guebwiller le
département du haut-rhin donc s'est
engagé dans la production d'énergie
renouvelable et donc nous sommes ici sur
le site d'une visite archimède qui a été
installé sur le sur la rivière la lauch
et qui est produite par les usines selon
mme berger qui sont juste derrière nous
alors c'est une vie ce qui fait qu'il
fait à peu près 37 k b 1 qui est donc
une vis qui produit l'électricité qui
est injectée sur le réseau d'edf
nous avons cinq miss aujourd'hui qui
sont installés sur le département du
haut rhin une ici sur la loge et 4 qui
sont sur le
canal du rhône au rhin dans la plaine
l'enjeu c'est de produire de l'énergie
renouvelable évidemment mais c'est aussi
d'utiliser des baies et chute
il y assure le sur la loge pour ce type
de devises d'archimède que nous faisons
un parallèle avec une passe à poissons
pour permettre la continuité écologique
de la rivière faut savoir que cette
production représente à peu près
l'équivalent d'une production pour me
laver à un village de 1000 habitants
près de la louche bon nombre de
cyclistes et coureurs empruntent la
piste cyclable lors des beaux jours
à côté et en contrebas des vignobles se
trouve une des nombreuses passes à
poissons c'est un autre élément
important du canton qui permet de
maintenir l'équilibré écologique de
toute la zone
il y en a plusieurs sur le sur le canton
la visite est celle de guebwiller qui se
trouve juste en face de l'entrée de la
communauté de communes
elle permet la continuité écologique de
ces de ces espèces animales dans le
respect évidemment de leur environnement
dernier arrêt de notre parcours à
issenheim commune peuplée d'environ 3500
habitants un kilomètre et demi de
guebwiller
là bas se trouve l'usiné original
propriété de l'entreprise alpro sogenal
a su se faire une place dans le paysage
économique du canton et participe
grandement à son rayonnement
en parallèle l'entreprise profite de sa
position privilégiée et a vu sa
production augmenter
donc nous nous trouvons maintenant en
conclusion de ce cycle de l'eau nous
trouvons sur le parking de l'entreprise
ce final a le projet final à issenheim
qui est une usine de production de lait
de soja et pourquoi c'était usine s'est
implanté ici chez nous tout simplement
parce qu'elle recherchait une qualité
d'eau exemplaire et que l a trouvée dans
le dans le processus de production d'eau
potable du florival la qualité d'eau qui
convenait à son processus de production
de l'extérieur et donc c'est une usine
qui est en pleine expansion puisqu'elle
va tripler sa production d'ici la fin de
l'année pour
avec une augmentation d'emploi de
pratiquement 200 personnes ou quand
l'eau est la source de la réussite
pourvu qu'elle suive son cours